[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsables el
programa de france 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas el conflicto
en ucrania cumple un mes esta semana una
guerra que deja ya miles de muertos y
que ha obligado a más de 10 millones de
personas a desplazarse de sus hogares
según naciones unidas más de 35 millones
de ellos hoy por hoy son refugiados en
quiebra en la capital muchos se preparan
ante la posibilidad de una embestida por
parte del ejército ruso decretando
toques de queda y recogiendo los
escombros de ataques cada vez más
frecuentes contra zonas residenciales
nuestros reporteros james android y
jonathan walls fueron al encuentro de
una de las organizaciones que preparan
voluntarios para combatir en la defensa
territorial ucrania
voy aquí cualquiera que sea la noticia
que reciba hoy haz que la reciba con una
actitud firme sabiendo que es tu santa
voluntad lamento ya sé otra bola
alec es un pastor protestante y un
combatiente voluntario está preparando
esta unidad para la batalla
estos chicos van a firmar su contrato de
defensa territorial van a defender que
la mayoría de ellos no tienen
experiencia así que nuestro objetivo es
entrenarlos eso es lo que hemos estado
haciendo en las últimas dos semanas
entrenar a los chicos preparando los
para ir al frente
estos nuevos reclutas están a punto de
alistarse durante tres años muchos de
ellos empuñan un fusil de asalto por
primera vez las unidades de defensa
territorial forman parte oficialmente de
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania pero
tienen su propia cadena de mando
como todos los comandantes de esta
unidad es miembro de la organización de
nacionalistas ucranianos
para mí
y yo es una fuerza creada por nuestros
antepasados para defender nuestro país y
ucrania es un famoso símbolo de la lucha
por la libertad de ucrania por todo el
ucraniano que rusia ha tratado de
suprimir y destruir completamente
durante 400 años
la aún se creó hace casi un siglo para
luchar contra el dominio soviético en
ucrania durante la segunda guerra
mundial colaboró activamente con los
nazis contra el enemigo común law
desde 2014 la aún lucha contra los
separatistas apoyados por rusia en el
donbass junto con otras organizaciones
nacionalistas como a su propio sector su
participación es el núcleo del mensaje
propagandístico ruso que afirma que
ucrania está en manos de los nazis según
no le sólo un puñado de miembros tienen
opiniones extremistas
son people
[Música]
son tipo algunas personas están al
límite no como organización sino algunas
personas de esas organizaciones
putin nos llaman nazis pero mi respuesta
sería que no matamos a civiles que
amamos a nuestro país eso nos convierte
en nazis no lo creo
en el censo
nos llevan a una de las bases de primera
línea de la un al oeste de kiev los
jóvenes reclutas que están siendo
entrenados pronto serán desplegados en
posiciones como esta
esta es una de nuestras posiciones más
importantes están intentando atacar
quiére desde dos direcciones desde el
norte y el oeste y esta es una de ellas
hace dos días estaban 800 metros nuestro
ataque los hizo retroceder en esta
jugada de un monton drum
con la invasión rusa en marcha la une
está reclutando y haber desplegado más
de 500 combatientes en todo el país
nadie sabe a ciencia cierta cuántos
soldados ucranianos han perdido la vida
desde que inició el conflicto y dadas
las cifras tan dispares reconocidas por
un lado porque a mí por el otro por
moscú es absolutamente imposible saber
cuántos soldados rusos han muerto desde
el inicio de la guerra lo único cierto
es que muchas de estas víctimas son
personas extremadamente jóvenes cuyas
muertes se lloran en ambos bandos como
lo reportan irene sabio y leticia
álvarez
volodymyr era un estudiante de la
academia militar de hierro beef tenía
sólo 22 años el día del ataque ruso
estaba con el resto de sus compañeros
en la iglesia de la guarnición de los
santos apóstoles pedro y pablo del ibi
se celebran funerales cada día desde que
empezó el ataque ruso no hay tregua en
esta guerra que deja viudas huérfanos y
madres sin hijos
el cura román men tube conocí a
volodymyr y al resto de soldados de la
región a los que acompaña cada día
lo más difícil es entender que yo a ese
chico lo conocía en persona y que a él
como a muchos otros soldados que he
conocido no tendré la oportunidad de
verlos de nuevo o tomarme un café con
ellos o hablar
efe
o taras es un seminarista greco-católico
que ha vivido desde el primer día esta
guerra que empezó en el 2014 por amar su
país su gente
porque quería su país de verdad qué
es que me duele cuando son jóvenes como
yo
de 20 bueno yo tengo 26 pero eso es que
tienen menos que yo 20 años o 2022 que
han muerto en la guerra en la guerra por
ucrania
la guerra es también una madre que llora
el cementerio del ibi fue destrozado
durante la segunda guerra mundial ahora
vuelve a los soldados caídos en la
guerra de rusia en ucrania
en ucrania la muerte y la destrucción
forman parte del paisaje diario como la
sirena de una ambulancia o la de una
alerta antiaérea
y bueno franquista es una de las
ciudades del oeste de ucrania donde
todavía se respira un cierto aire de
normalidad al menos en apariencia sin
embargo la vida está marcada por la
guerra y los habitantes intentan
adaptarse a esta nueva realidad muchos
intentan ayudar poniendo un granito de
arena para la defensa del país así ello
implique grandes sacrificios informe de
catalina gómez ángel y oriola andrés
gallardo
en circunstancias habituales botana
estaría hasta ahora en el restaurante
donde trabaja como chef pero la
intuición nos ha cambiado sus
prioridades
y
en general han pasado dos semanas desde
que comenzó la guerra
y ahora que han empezado los
entrenamientos me siento mucho más
segura
como madre soltera fontana quiere estar
preparada para proteger a su hijo como
ella cada uno de estos voluntarios de
las unidades de defensa territorial
creen que si quieren conservar su país
tienen que protegerlo
siempre hemos estado preparados para la
agresión rusa desde 2014 supimos que
donbass y crimea no iban a ser sus
últimos objetivos
y bueno frank bis tiene trescientos mil
habitantes a pesar de que la guerra no
se siente como en otros lugares de
ucrania la vida está marcada por ella
como en este café donde apoyan a quienes
llegan de otras regiones por supuesto ya
en lo personal me reúno con la gente que
muchas veces viene con los ojos llorosos
y los apoyamos moralmente los calmamos
le decimos que todo va a estar bien
y estados estables
nicola tuvo que reaccionar rápido
después de la invasión la decisión
pasaba por mantener abierta su cadena de
pizzerías samur y los propietarios de
restaurantes decidimos organizarnos y
acordamos ayudar a militares voluntarios
y refugiados
ahora tiene la responsabilidad de
alimentar alrededor de 250 militares a
quienes provee dos veces al día
desde el principio de la invasión rusa
podemos sentir cómo la gente está unida
y cada uno apoya al ejército bolsa la
oficina de registro civil está más
ocupada que de costumbre decenas de
parejas han decido casarse a última hora
muchos de ellos son militares que tienen
que ir a la guerra con las situaciones
que nosotros no sabemos qué pasará
mañana y estamos enamorados queremos
pasar el resto de nuestra vida juntos
para todos los planes han quedado
detenidos has nuevo sus sueños y por eso
luchan por protegerlos
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
aprobó un proyecto de ley que busca
revocar el estatus de rusia como nación
más favorecida esto supondría un aumento
en las tarifas de los bienes y servicios
que ese país le vende a la unión
americana el boicot ya se siente en las
calles de la gran manzana donde muchos
negocios cuyos propietarios son rusos
ven con preocupación un descenso
significativo en el número de clientes
como nos lo cuentan desde nueva york
nuestra corresponsal mamen sanz
desde que comenzó la guerra en este
restaurante ruso han caído las reservas
más de un 60% por eso vlada su
propietaria quiere dejar claro que aquí
abren cada día pero el mensaje más
importante sin duda está en la puerta
queremos estar seguros que la gente que
viene a comer aquí entiende que su
dinero no va a apoyar putin su régimen
turno de los de origen en el interior
las mesas están vacías hoy sólo tienen
cinco reservas algo inusual en este
emblemático negocio de manhattan donde
hasta ahora era casi imposible conseguir
una mesa y han dejado de venir la gente
está cancelando las reservas que
hicieron antes de la guerra los diversos
ironías de la vida hablada nación san
petesburgo su hijo nicolás es americano
y el patriarca de la familia ucraniano
de la portuaria odessa ahora bajo
amenaza rusa sólo porque este es un
establecimiento ruso no significa que le
damos a putin dinero pero no todo el
mundo lo ve igual y ellos se están
cargando la culpa de una guerra que no
apoyan
me he levantado con una llamada
telefónica diciendo en ruso eres ruso y
palabras que no puedo decir al aire
cosas como ojalá te mueras nací y siendo
judío que te llamen así no tiene sentido
axis
los negocios rusos de la gran manzana
cada vez se sienten más presionados
sobre todo después de que joe biden
prohibió la entrada a este país donde
productos estrellas rusos como los
diamantes el pescado el marisco el
caviar y el vodka
oportunidad perfecta para la entrada de
otras marcas nos cuenta este
distribuidor de licores
muy vivo lisván hoy
leonard filis el propietario de la
licorería tiene familia en ucrania por
eso aquí el alcohol ruso recoge fondos
para la causa ucraniana we walk town y
vamos a donar una parte de las ventas a
una iglesia ucraniana oa una
organización que apoye la causa
ucraniana sort y cuando se acaben las
existencias no se comprará más y se
apostará por otro tipo de licores esto
es christina un vodka ucraniano con el
que hemos trabajado desde hace años y
que siempre hemos tenido así es cómo
estos dos negocios con productos rusos
condenan una guerra que viven a
distancia pero sufren muy de cerca
queremos agradecer al museo de arte
moderno de bogotá por prestarnos sus
instalaciones para la realización de
este programa y muchas gracias a ustedes
por seguir una emisión más de
corresponsables nos damos cita la
próxima semana siga con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom